the Academy is heavy with honors tonight
and to honor a most unusual veteran of
the most unusual aspect of filmmaking
here is a former Oscar winner the
president of the Screen Actors Guild
who's made Andrew Jackson El Cid Moses
and Michael Angelo all looked like
Charlton Heston
thank you Bob half a century ago 22 year
old cowboy with both brains and guts
stepped in front of a movie camera for
the first time one of the first things
he learned was that movies should move
and he spent his life ever since making
sure they do before movies could even
talk he'd already perform some
incredible stunts that have since become
legendary and by the time he'd made his
reputation as the greatest stuntman of
all time he devised special safety
devices and stunt techniques that are
still used by the men who make up the
profession to which he gave so much but
that's only half the story of the
remarkable man we're honoring tonight
when he stopped doing the stunts himself
he became what the firm film world
acknowledges as the most talented
director of action sequences ever to put
motion on the screen take any half-dozen
of his credits boomtown Ben Hur
stagecoach L seed Gone with the Wind
cartoon and you'll see some of the
reasons why the Board of Directors is
honoring him tonight with his special
award
I'm very proud to present it to him and
I'm proud to tell you what he'd never
say himself he deserves it his name is
yakima canutt
not so much not so much for what I have
enjoyed doing my all these years myself
and hope to continue doing but in the
name of all those stunt men and women
who kept defying busted Bulls Bastian
heads to make pictures more real and
reality more picturesque they are a
great gang and I'm honored you chose me
to honor them now what is it we saddle
up and get some action